hi reject nation I'm Greg and I'm Tara
Tara Erickson is here so there's a
channel a do name ADAC the one he did
his final try not to laugh challenge but
then on April 1st which is obviously an
April Fool's thing he did it try not to
laugh challenge I I don't think there's
an actual try not to laugh okay but
let's watch this anyway because Edith
the one has been a big supporter of our
channel for a long time he's made some
hilarious try not to last and I thought
let's check out what he has going for us
today Tara okay I gotta try not to laugh
I don't want to tell you right now I
don't know if it's an app let's watch
the video watching you will be
challenged
[Music]
hey it's like matching your shirt
Oh panic at the disco hey it's in thick
raelia see me sorry guys this is an
April Fool's joke by to eat the one I
wish I could see your faces right now
look don't turn off this video just yet
this is a challenge video it's called a
deep the ones try not to turn off the
video challenge so we can laugh find out
good luck everybody and Happy Easter for
me and a date the one okay
oh god is it just gonna be this the
whole time it's like the Terminator
[Music]
[Music]
okay this is a weird video
so just like a bunch of annoying clips
and I'm not sure yeah we should just
turn I get it now I would be like off
next Oh weird
all right let's get you plugged in I'm
so excited for this move figure out our
bond line okay hey blind wave
[Music]
[Music]
I know this video you're seeing that
video
Oh what is that
I think he's just screeching oh okay
how do his torturing an animal yes that
would have been really funny
[Music]
bring the footage
ause auntie-ji Wyatt with the TDF turbo
she doesn't
[Music]
hey um do you think maybe you and me
good oh I've been there what is the goal
of this video I don't know I'm half
asleep right now on the inside
playing like I'm entertain but I'm
really bored I don't know what's
happening
boy
if I was by myself you would turn it off
I would shirt off when this video ends
I'm gonna think wow I wasted so much of
my life
[Music]
oh man that's fun
Tyron mostest we just go matter I'm so
happy for this guys has such a thriving
career after Blue's Clues it's amazing
how far he's gone right
[Music]
hey it's Charles - or some
[Music]
looks like a fun game
[Music]
Mike check this out man that's the is it
new just got it seven inches longer
handle spray power I take this bad boy
oh look at the respect you get some
respect with that my girlfriend who
loves the new Dutch traffic come now
resurfacing APR financing ride the
stretcher use left at bright directional
buttons to steer avoid carsick both your
bikes you should come by tomorrow he'll
be waxing it basically what you're
saying is I can just edit in a bunch of
clips into a video game million reveal
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah we won we won like winning we won a
deep the won we won I'm glad we won I'm
really happy we won we won we did it
I've never won any of these challenges
before every try not to laugh I kind of
laugh trying to cringe it's hard not to
crying - cringes can be harder yeah this
one trying to turn off might have been
the most challenging challenge might
have been I agree with you you made a
good challenge inspired me to pull
together some really snooze fest clips
and put them into a video and put it
online I just want to do a ten minute
clip of me doing nails on a chalkboard
and call it a try not to turn off this
video yeah I just want to do the girl
trying a jump and not jumping for a good
20 minutes
try not to turn off that video I feel
like I accomplished something I could at
least say I I made it to meet it this is
VIP this is why YouTube was made to do
videos like this I agree you know 110
percent he's in the right he's in the
right path if people thought reactions
were
unless they haven't seen anything they
haven't seen nothing yes there and I
have ideas brewing there's so many ideas
unique edits coming out of all the areas
oh I don't know I guess holes can all
over producing openings yeah ideas can
come out of all those areas areas yeah
and there and boy do they come quick and
hard if you're here listening to this
all right now the extended version of
for this challenge that you can can you
keep this on this is like Wham what
they're talking about now it's pointless
right but it's not can you what I
haven't clicked off the video clicked
off nobody click stop not yet yes
playing the video try not to turn up try
not to turn try not to turn that turned
it Wow
turning chairs with headphones not a
good idea not a good idea he'll come in
here I'll go behind here and you guys
will step play the video I still play it
are you guys still playing I think we
need a third I lasted longer than
Humphrey ah are you tapping the mic so
you can't hear me little I'm just making
sure that it works I'm gonna making sure
the mic well I'm making sure the mic
where I'm making sure the cameras gonna
cut automatically imitation how great
you